foreign
rise to the terms data science and data
analytics to more industry buzzwords big
data and data science jobs have long
been a sure option for anybody looking
for long-term career Prospect as Ai and
machine learning becoming deeply
ingrained into our society and economy
this tendency is likely to persist for
very long data science is the new oil
that companies are using to gain crucial
insights boost operations and expand
their market share but who will gain
knowledge who will handle the raw data
that has been compiled a data analyst or
data scientist handles everything as
businesses all around the world try to
make the most of data these are the two
most common job titles in this field
from this video we will understand the
difference between data science and data
analytics but before moving forward
please make sure you subscribe to Simply
learns YouTube channel and never miss
any up if you are an aspiring data
scientist we have a best offer for you
simply learn offers data science master
program in collaboration with IBM please
find the link of the course in the
description box below but before moving
forward I would like to ask a question
for you who coined the term data science
Andre burko Peter nor John mashay John
McCarthy answer the question in the
comment section below now what's in it
for you first we will understand
introduction to data science as well as
data analytics next is what does data
scientists do and what does data analyst
do after that we will discuss role of
data scientist versus data analytics in
the industry skills of data scientist
versus data analytics jobs in data
science versus data analytics what is
data science data science is an
interdisciplinary field that deals with
data this brings together data analytics
machine learning and artificial
intelligence all together in data
science we use massive amounts of data
utilizing relevant tools and techniques
to design valuable data the day-to-day
work of a data scientist involves
collecting analyzing and interpreting
this data to help businesses achieve
their goal data analytics explores and
analyzes large data sets to find
patterns and unseen records discover
correlations and derive valuable insight
to make business predictions
data analytics is a distinct field in
and itself as well as one of the
discipline that falls under data science
umbrella which means data analytics is
the subset of data science data
scientists tend to ask broad strategic
questions via data analysts typically
have more focused functions looking for
solutions to more particular issues now
coming to what is data scientist and
data analysts do what does data
scientists do a data scientist job is
involved in creating algorithms and
predictive models data scientists are
involving creating tools and data
Frameworks while treating data very
rigorously data scientistic raw data and
turn it into a wealth of information
that provides answer to questions for
companies looking for solutions to their
problems data scientists may be more
focused than a data analyst on creating
new tools and techniques to obtain
information a company needs to tackle
challenging problems to understand the
implications of the data it is also
advantages to have business intuition
and critical thinking abilities a data
scientist is someone who not only
understand math and statistics but also
has the hacker ability to solve problems
creatively according to several in the
industry what does a data analyst do
data analyst often use tools like sqlr
or Python programming language data
visualization software and statistical
analysis to work with structured data
typical task of a data analyst could be
identifying information needs in
collaboration with leaders of the
organization rearranging rearranging and
cleaning up data for analysis examining
data set to find patterns and trends
that can be turned into knowledge that
can be put to use for the welfare of the
project now we will focus on role of
data scientists and data analysis data
scientists concentrate on the large data
of the organization it is the work of
data scientists to work on unstructured
data with the help of machine learning
and artificial intelligence now coming
to role of data analysis data analysis
is a part of data science focused on the
smart part of the data using specific
software tools they mostly work with
structured data now we will focus on
skills and tools used by data scientists
and data analysts many similarities in
the tools and skills in both data
science and data analytics a data
scientist develops unique method for
collecting and analyzing data to be used
by data analyst whereas a data analyst
makes meaning of already collected data
if you enjoy both computer programming
and math and statistics any career route
might be a suitable fit for you
professional aspirin and analyst often
concentrate on providing detailed answer
regarding the company's operations in
order to create Innovative approaches
for posing and responding to significant
problems a data scientist May operate at
a more macro level more precisely data
analyst must be well versed in SQL data
analysis for casting with Advanced Excel
creating dashboards and Reporting based
on the availability when it comes to
data scientist a data scientist must be
able to understand one of the languages
that is python or are employing machine
learning methods for statistical
analysis such as KNL algorithm random
Forest logistic regression natural
language processing or gradient boosting
it was used by data scientists and data
analysts are almost similar a data
scientist typically uses Tableau Excel
Matlab Apaches Park and IDE for
programming languages like python or R
regarding data analytics Excel power bi
tab blue and Apache spark is widely used
tools used by data scientists and
analysts are almost similar data
scientists typically uses Tableau Excel
Matlab Apache spark and IDE for
programming languages like python or R
regarding data analytics we use tab blue
Excel power bi and Apache Spark as tools
the salary of a data analyst as well as
data scientist varies based on the
experience level according to
glassdoor.com in India a fresher will
get a salary of 8 lakhs per annum for
data scientist on an average
an experience level data scientist
salary may go as high as 20 lakhs per
annum
for refresher in a data analyst fee they
will get salary as 6 lakhs per annum and
it can go as high as 10 lakhs per annum
and go beyond that if you have
experience
coming to us
the average salary of a data scientist
will be 80 000 it can go as high as two
hundred thousand dollars per annum
coming to data analyst it can go as high
as seventy thousand dollars per annum
for refresher and for experienced data
scientist it can go as high as hundred
thousand dollars per year that comes to
an end of similarities and differences
in data science and data analytics with
the aid of insights derived from the
data present in the company businesses
are seeing enormous profit and growth
the number of employment openings for
data scientists and data analyst has
significantly increased the number of
employment openings for data scientists
and data analyst has significantly
increased because of this in every form
the most important component of every
firm nowadays is data data science is
helpful in uncovering Practical insights
from unstructured and raw data set
finding answers to queries that the
organization needs to be aware of is the
emphasis of this field I hope you
enjoyed watching this video but before
ending this video I would like to answer
the query for the question who coined
the term data science the answer for the
question is Peter no I hope you found
this video interesting thank you for
watching the video keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you